PROFESSOR: We have a problem.
The general perturbation
theory, again, end states.
But this time, the
degeneracy is not broken.
So degeneracy not
lifted at first order.
Surprisingly, this subject
is, as you can see,
you have to do things with care.
It's not in any of the
textbooks that I know.
In fact, I don't
know of any place
where it is discussed in
detail or discussed anywhere,
even though this result is
pretty useful and you need it,
and I think people
improvise when they do this.
Even this discussion
that with it here is not
in any of your textbooks.
In [INAUDIBLE],, the
advanced quantum mechanics,
there's some discussion
and mentions this factor
and how subtle it is, but
doesn't quite do everything
till the bitter end.
This case is harder.
This is simple compared to
what we're going to do now.
But we're going to sketch it
so that you see the picture.
We're going to do
everything, but we're
going to try to keep
the picture clear
because it gets sophisticated.
So what's the situation
that is happening.
Physically, you have lambda
here, and you have the state.
And to first order,
they don't split.
So there are four states.
And what we will assume is
that the first order, they
don't split.
So they sort of come together.
And then to second
order, they will split.
We will assume that the
second order, they will split.
If they don't split the second
order, things get complicated.
I'm actually curious about that.
But I don't know of
any physics example
that they don't split to
first nor to second order.
You will have in the
homework things that
don't split to first order.
That really happens often.
Then to second order,
if you have four states
and then split, means
that the second order
they'll go like this.
And they'll start
looking like that
maybe, something like that.
So the slope is the
same to begin with,
but then they split.
OK.
So degeneracy not
lifted at first order.
So what is the problem here
that the degeneracy is not
lifted to first order?
The problem is physically that
this concept of a good basis,
that basis that corresponds
to the continuous changing
eigenstates.
You did the perturbation
theory to first order,
and you still don't know
what is the good basis.
Because the good
basis is the one
that the states
change continuously.
So suppose that we had
an example where we've
had in two dimensions the
conventional eigenstates,
1 0, and 0 1, but the good
basis was the 1 1 and 1 minus 1.
And you would say,
oh, they jumped.
But you have to choose
the right basis.
You do first order to
generate perturbation theory.
And if the states split,
you have the good basis.
But if they don't
split, you have
no idea what is the good basis.
So in that sense, you're
trying to go high,
because we did first order.
Now, you have to go to second
order of perturbation theory
to see if you can find
what the good basis is.
So we will have to diagonalize
something to second order
to find the good basis.
And once you have
the good basis,
you sort of have to
start from the beginning.
Now, I have a good basis.
Let's do the perturbation
theory nicely.
So if the degeneracy
not broken, we
have that n0k delta H
and 0l is en1 delta kl.
It is diagonal still.
You do have a basis that
diagonalizes the perturbation.
You still diagonalize it.
But once you diagonalize it, all
the eigenvalues are the same.
There's no account for ml here.
All of them are the same.
So what is the catch?
The catch is that you now
need to find good eigenstates.
So what is the good basis?
We'll write it in
the following way.
I will form linear combinations
k equal 1 to n of the n0k.
And I will put
coefficients a, k, 0 here.
And I will say, look, if you
give me some coefficients a, k,
0, I know how to superimpose
now the N states.
And let's hope that that's
one good basis vector.
You know, I've written one
good basis vector if a, k
it's a column vector of numbers.
It gives me what is the
superposition of those
degenerate states
that makes one vector.
So I'll call this
a vector PSI 0.
So I think of this a, k
not as unknown numbers,
unknown vector that
specifies a good state.
And moreover, if
I do things right,
I should calculate these things.
And I should find that my
equations end up giving me
N of those good vectors.
You see, if I specify a column
vector of constants here,
I get one vector here,
a linear superposition.
But I should get n
linear superpositions.
Because at the end
of the day, there
has to be n good
vectors in that basis.
So in some sense, I hope
for an a0 with an index Ik,
with I going from 1 to n,
in which this by varying I
provides me k N column
vectors, each one of which
gives me a state.
So this gives me one state.
If I had N of
those coefficients,
I would get n state.
So that's my hope.
So suppose we get one
of those good states,
how should it look in
perturbation theory?
Well, the state PSI lambda is
going to be the state PSI 0.
That's, in fact, the
zeroth order state.
We don't know
those coefficients.
That's our ignorance about
the zeroth order states now.
PSI 0 plus lambda PSI 1 plus.
And the energy's en lambda
is en 0, the 0 energy,
plus the first order
energy correction
plus the second order
energy corrections.
And from this, the
Schrodinger equation
that as usual says that
h of lambda PSI of lambda
is equal to En of
lambda PSI of lambda
gives you these equations that,
by now, you're pretty familiar.
And we'll need a couple of them.
So I will write them again.
To order lambda 0, you get H0
minus En0 on PSI 0 equal 0.
That's a trivial
equation because PSI 0
is made up of states, all
of which have energy En0.
So that's always a
trivial equation.
Then to order lambda,
you have H0 minus En0
on the first state.
We've done this
already a few times.
So I'm sure you don't have
trouble believing this.
And to order lambda squared,
the last one that I'll write,
En0 PSI 2 is equal to En1 minus
delta H PSI 1 plus En2 PSI 0.
OK.
Kind of tire of writing
these equations.
OK.
So let's see what we should do.
So we can start
calculating things.
And the way I'm going to do
it, for the benefit of time,
is that I will
indicate the steps
and what you do and
skip the algebra.
It will all be in the notes.
And in fact, the whole
calculation will,
if you want to go to
the very end of it
and exploit it to
a maximum, there's
lots of things one can do.
And some of that will
be left for homework.
So our idea here is to
give you the road map
and for you to see how
we're doing things.
So let me see here.
We can do a few things
with these equations.
So the first
equation is trivial,
so we don't bother with it.
And the second
equation, it's kind of
interesting to see what it does.
We can find from this
equation a confirmation
of what first order
perturbation theory does.
If we inject here one
of the states in VN,
those N0l's, you get
the statement, again,
that delta H should
diagonalize the perturbation.
So I think I'll skip that.
We'll discuss it in the notes.
But let's do the case when
this equation gives something
non-trivial.
So let's calculate p acting
on the order lambda equation.
So when we had N0l, say, on
the order lambda equation,
that is kind of familiar.
We've already done it a
few times, so I'll skip it.
But let's do the p
acting on this equation.
So p0 H0 minus
En0 times PSI 1 is
equal to p0 En1
minus delta H PSI 0.
H0 is a known Hamiltonian.
And this we know the energy.
So this gives you Ep0 minus
En0 on p0 PSI 1 is equal to.
Here is a state in v-hat.
And this is a state in
the degenerate subspace.
We wrote it up there.
That's our answers.
We don't know even the
zeroth order states.
That's our problem.
But this term is
orthogonal to that.
So across the number,
it gives us 0.
On the other hand,
here what do we get?
We get minus the sum.
Think of this state
being the sum that we
wrote in the previous thing.
The sum from k equal 1
to n delta Hp nk a0 k.
I've substituted this formula
for the state PSI 0 in there.
And now, we have
computed these overlaps
because this is in principle
known in terms of a0.
And now we have these
constants, these overlaps
of the states outside
the general space
with the first
correction and this part.
So I'll write it this way.
PSI 1 of v-hat is
equal to p ap1 p0.
And what is this ap1?
It's those coefficients
we're trying to find here.
So this is the component
of PSI 1 along p0.
So that component
should go here.
And therefore, it's minus
1 over Ep minus En0 all.
And here we have sum from k
equals 1 to n delta H and Hp nk
ak0.
OK.
So we're pretty close to
our goal, believe it or not.
So what have we achieved?
Let's see, again, where we are.
We have no idea what
are the good states,
so we introduced a0.
a0 parameterizes our
ignorance of the good states.
So we know, however, that
the first order correction
doesn't lift the degeneracy.
And therefore, I don't
have to recalculate that
from the second equation.
I just find the piece
of PSI 1 that is also
determined from that equation.
And now, we've done completely
the first order equation.
And what did we learn?
We learned that the first
order correction to the state
is known if I know
the good basis.
Because all this first order
correction to the state
in the outside subspace in the
rest is determined if I know
the a0's.
But I don't know the a0's.
So we are calculating
things, but we have not
solved our problem.
But we run out of equations
with the order lambda.
We've finished.
No more lambda equation, so we
have to look into this equation
now.